environment ministers will discuss
sustainability issues linked to the
development of the energy Union when
they meet in Russells on march six the
energy union is a major project aiming
to reform how europe produces transports
and consumes energy ministers will
examine how best to achieve that change
for instance by using more energy from
renewable sources and becoming more
energy efficient the outcome of the
debate will be forwarded to the
President of the European Council ahead
of the March meeting of EU leaders
ministers will also continue
preparations for the UN climate change
conference taking place in Paris in
December this conference aims to adopt a
new legally binding agreement on climate
change they will also have an exchange
of views on the post-2015 agenda it
should establish the new global
partnership for poverty eradication and
sustainable development due to be
adopted by the UN in September a deal in
this agenda will also have important
implications for negotiations on the new
climate change agreement